great pleasure prime minister for less
than three weeks and already taking to
the podium on the world stage on a day
when Russia threatened nuclear war a
moment for Liz trust to make her mark
That's about words but delivery too
no one is threatening Russia
yet as we meet here this evening
in Ukraine
the kill and maim people
rape is being used as an instrument of
War families are being torn apart and
this morning we have seen Putin trying
to justify his catastrophic failures
her late night address followed a
passionate speech from Ukraine's
president zielinski video linked from
Kiev
Russia once wore its true but Russia
will not be able to stop the cause of
History
Mankind and their international law are
stronger than one terrorist State though
he couldn't see it the reaction was the
one he'd wanted
as for President Putin's Stark nuclear
threats well this wasn't the moment for
off the cuff responses prime minister
what'd you make of Vladimir Putin's
comments this morning
is it time for NATO to double down for
the EU to Double Down
there was anticipation instead for how
America's President Biden would react to
the language from Moscow well here he is
arriving just now a little later than
planned and with a speech that has been
altered as a consequence of what Mr
Putin has been saying
and from the podium he was blunt and he
was firm
we do not seek conflict
we do not seek a cold war
a nuclear war
cannot be won
and must never be fought then from the
chamber to the first one-on-one meeting
with prime minister trust we are
supporting the ukrainians in their fight
for freedom but we Face huge challenges
Ukraine the focus of course and
naturally a united front but the body
language was stiff two nations with a
special relationship yes but two leaders
with very different politics and no
obvious rapport
the next Focus here later today a
security council meeting of foreign
ministers watch for a clash of words
Russia's Sergey lavrov opposite
America's Tony blinken and Britain's new
foreign secretary James cleverley Mark
Stone Sky News in New York